right well hello and welcome to the
machine learning panel my name's Peter
Bartlett
I'm from UC Berkeley and I guess first
of all welcome to the Simons Institute
for the theory of computer so the
Institute's been around since 2012 and
has four programs every year they last
the semester and the machine learning
program there's a program going on this
semester on foundations of machine
learning and we're all involved in in
that program
so the timers Institute has these
programs to bring people together so
focus on a particular research topic
where theoretical computer science can
make a contribution so you bring each
each one bring something like 40 in
Berkeley and around 10 more junior
people for instance new PhDs and runs
something like four workshops during
throughout that semester so let me
introduce the other panel members so shy
then David is community Waterloo
University Yale University and andreas
crowds from Zurich so the topic of the
panel is is machine learning and I
wanted to start by giving you a few
examples of places where machine
learning has had a big impact on our
lives already so you know maybe this is
all familiar to you but maybe not so I
guess every time you talk to Siri and
say finally a coffee shop or you know
ask ask for directions the system that
sees that audio signals turns it into
the sequence of phonemes the sequence of
words understand what you want and
respond with appropriate directions or
obvious decisions that's that's based on
machining technology an essential part
of them and that sort of speech
recognition technologies improved
enormously in the last in the last
period as a result of advanced imaging
so another areas image understanding so
we have systems now that can take a raw
image and from that image draw a box
around objects of interest and respond
with a caption like this is two people
riding on horses or you know here's a
bus in front of a red brick house things
of that sort so you know it's really
quite a sophisticated um example of
being able to understand images and
you'll see a lot more of this sort of
technology appearing in everything I
natural language processing you've
probably all play it with Google
Translate so again no machine learning
is behind the success of this sort of
automated translation so here I've taken
actually the abstract for the channel
and put it through google translate from
English to French to English to German
to English and you know we get actually
something that's really rather group and
that's that's a big improvement again so
you're translating words word has has
been a bit but you know coming out with
sentences that are coherences and make
sense that that reflects the context of
the rest of us of the document that's
actually a big improvement in the last
either twelve months so September last
year Google upgraded the machine
learning that they were using for Google
Translate and that basically an
improvement in that direction and it was
described but now if you play with this
but Skype has again
technology that will take you know your
spoken utterances understand those
translate them into whatever other
language twists and the other end is
speaking and you can carry on a
conversation between languages in that
way again notice machine learning is a
technology time that another high
profile success parser is alphago system
about a year ago played lead feed all at
the game of goes so seagull was the
eighteen times world champion at go and
we defeated him pretty sandwich for
format before games to one in that in
that match there was a million dollar
prize up so that for this and you know
again the techniques that were used here
- for the alphago systems were based on
using using training data and learning
catechol okay so so many examples of
this sort let me say just a little bit
at a very high level of what machine
learning is all about and do that by way
of this example you know we can think of
a machine learning system is wanting to
come up with a prediction rule let's
call it which is something that takes an
input for instance an image has
producers announced and output an
appropriate caption for that image maybe
a labeling or or description of what's
in the image and we can think of that
prediction rule that something we can
adjust you know there are you know I've
drawn shown it here as a box with a huge
number of knobs and think of it as you
know somehow by changing those logs
we're changing the mapping that we get
from this image to you know whatever
captions come out okay it's very very
much a cartoon picture there are no
knobs these are you know variables in
some computer program somewhere but you
know a nice cartoon to imagine what's
going on here and how those knobs
adjustable on the basis of training
so we will gather together a large
collection of images labeled with an
appropriate caption and use those to try
to work out what a sensible prediction
or to use in the setting so really key
ingredient here is is a training data
and in the cases that I showed you know
that might take the form of a lot of
audio signals and spoken utterances
together with the corresponding phonemes
right that were spoken or labeled images
of particular clips right or I can't
really read that you know this is the
Wizard of Oz and it's translation into
language I found you know so I get
labeled labeled training data of a
rather large scale or in the case of
alphago you know board positions from
the middle of some 30,000 30 million I'm
sorry go games right and this is that
together with perhaps some estimate of
how good it is to be in this position if
you're white okay so you know the broad
brush approach is to take this sort of
this sort of data and use been use that
to adjust the knobs to come up with a
prediction all that stuff something
sensible Indian very very situation okay
so the program that's on this semester
foundations of machine learning is all
about you know the theory behind that
technology trying to understand what are
the limitations the inherent limitations
in learning problems to understand how
we can develop machine learning systems
for which we can give performance
guarantees and so there are some areas
where where theory has had a lot to
contribute and the theories rather well
develop other areas where you know there
are many rather fundamental things we
just don't understand and there's a lot
of common effort and so we'll go through
a few
different examples a different effect
and Scot flows in them in the tackle
today we're going to start with shine
steadily talking about I guess the
information theoretic aspects of
learning theory and I'll talk about a
very basic principle functional so a
period perspective and I want to start
if you want to understand how machine
learning works maybe we should start
with understanding how learning works in
HR animal army air works so let me start
with this kind of amazing example of
success of learning so if you ever had
issues with red and you try to poison
right by a distributing base around it
turns out that words are very
sophisticated if they be a kind of safe
food they are not accustomed to they
will take a small only small taste of it
and if they feel sweet within several
hours later they will edge with the
thickness to this specific new a food
that they try and they will never take
it again
so this is called bait shyness they
learn from one experiment they taste a
little bit of food they go through the
rest of the day so one experiment they
learned is it's bits of food what's
poison that will never touch the gate
and it isn't a big issue for the farmers
that want to fight to fight when I mean
nowadays a last date for weight they
have a delay mechanism they deport the
magnetic effect only two days later and
by the vendor I can feel anything and
negative is positive so from the front
of your machine it's a big reason how
does the rest
does learning so efficiently from one
experiment it knows where to place the
to attribute the danger and learns the
lesson is crucial to the life of the
race but how do they do such successful
them maybe we can take some lessons of
that when we try to build machinery so
here is another so what is happening
here is just a description when they
can't put falling food they learn very
fast the cause of the causal
relationship between the taste and the
12 the food and the thickness is
followed hours later okay here is
another example from animals and this is
the schema was there maybe the fathom of
behaviorism in psychology and you have
this wonderful experiment experiment in
in 1948 he took pigeons we put them in a
in a cage he thousand little bit until
they lose 25% of their initial body
weight and then they're very hungry
and then what happened is that a
completely random intervals they spread
from the top of the cage they spray some
grain and then there's another interval
there the pigeon weight and another
spray of grain what is happening to the
pigeon so the problem is the point is
that pigeons when they are hungry they
are searching for food so each pigeon
gets involved in some activity so some
pigeon is turning right and left another
pigeon is trying to peck at the corner
of the cage another pigeon is trying to
Bandhan and flex and then suddenly the
count the food so they attribute the
occurrence of the food to the last
activity that have been doing so now
there will be two doing this activity
more often because this is connected
with food so the next time the food
cards they get even more enforcement of
this activity we do
after a family with this for a day each
of the pigeons is completely obsessed
with well activities one piece it isn't
about another one if they're speaking at
the column all the time
another one is just bending it and each
of the pigeons believe the bees will be
like the green for this is called pigeon
superstition and you can easily see
humans behaving in the same and the big
question for Isis cavitation is what is
the difference what makes the red so
successful well the regions are doing
such gentle why is learning successful
in one of them and what are they what
way are the West smarter than the pigeon
so there was this guy in a garcia here
in Berkeley in 1989 and he wanted to try
to understand better how the rest are so
successful so what is it if you replace
the stimulus associate with the
provisional base by making it sound when
we taste it so now we are again feeding
pigeons we use the bait but now they
made the extreme effort at the base you
look exactly and well exactly and tell
it exactly as they food there are a
couple so how are we going to warm the
red against the poison each time they
take a poisonous bait we wring a bit so
now we are doing the same experiment but
the cue to the poison is a bit so what
do you think what you get will direct
learn to avoid feeding whenever they
hear the bell and the answer is no they
fail to detect the connection between
the sound and the
sickness they do not refrain from eating
when the same warning sound is a sound
again why why is it happening how can we
explain it so why are they paying
attention to the noise and you can ask
other things I mean so then after the
see our people repeated it with the
electric shock with the flash of light
with all kinds of other types of
stimulus and the rest of them
why don't allow why can't we have just
improved well maybe we should develop
some kind of an improved way that will
be sensitive to light and sound and the
electricity and whatever what would be
the problem with an approved rest like
this if the rate will start paying
attention when it feeds on something it
will pay attention to what am i hearing
now what am i seeing now what do i feel
now what's the temperature what would
happen then yes what happening probably
a little information slowly of there's
no proper hierarchy of information
that's all correct for those even word
things if we pay attention to so many
variables then every food tasting is
different than another if you if you pay
attention if you feel sick at the end of
the day you you you throw up
okay if you akin a new restaurant that
you never ate them again you will
attribute it to the rest but if you
start paying attention to everything you
said oh it may be towards the breakfast
because it was the first time I had
breakfast at 9 or 1 usually I have
recognized I don't - oh maybe it was
lodged between the same time the during
lunch there was a cloud outside and
now Lance does no cloud so if you start
paying attention to everything that
every food tasting is very going to be
special we've never had such a thing
before
maybe that's why if the repeal and
finish Rick yeah so situation the rats
would be overfitting they will be
overthinking the data exactly that's the
technical person so the conclusion is
that we cannot have improved right that
will pay attention to any type of
stimulus because in that case every
testing of the food would be an outlier
in some respects there will be no way to
know which safety was responsible for
the sickness which brings us to the
toilet I don't know if everything on my
next slide or not but the main point
here is that what makes the rest of
successful compared to the pigeons is
that the rates are paying attention to
the relevant features the relevant
feature with food whether you will be
sick or not is the taste and the smell
of the food and the pigeons were there
saving them in the cage they don't have
any clue about what is the relevant
feature to the spraying of the grain so
there is a crucial issue of paying
attention to elephant vision and we
cannot pay attention to all the features
because then nothing in the world will
be a repetition of something that we
experienced before and this can be
mathematically phrased and this is what
we call no free lunch principle and it's
not about this lunch for the red it's
the in a sense that there is no learning
algorithm that can guarantee to be
successful on all possible phenomena
this can be learned a learning algorithm
must have some kind of what we call
inductive bias it is the rate learning
algorithm is biased towards paying
attention to taste and smell every
learning algorithm needs to know what
the relevant features and have an
inductive bias
it tends to apply some kind of
phrenology we cannot have a universal
best level so when you read now the
stories about deep learning and how
everything will be automated and we will
not need any human intervention we can
mathematically prove that this is not
the case don't worry we will always need
some prior knowledge the fool proved
very mathematically we can show that
there is no learner that will succeed on
all tasks is there is no student that
will be at the same time the best unit
in mass in the best violinist and the
best dancer and the best set on Joanne
to the girls and everybody has their own
areas of success yes right right so what
I'm saying is what the crucial V is
applying prior knowledge you need to
know something about your problem to get
started and the prior knowledge of the
rate we can ask how do they get this
prior knowledge but it is two
generations of fair you know natural
selection and yes what are the
implications of this not matter for
these mathematical ideas on the creation
of artificial right so the basically the
implication is that that's a very good
point I mean what I'm saying is Chris a
feature selection is crucial to learn
how to know the correct region and
physically selection is a big challenge
for for machine learning and it relies
on prior knowledge and we can try to
understand how did we collect all of
this data I mean the rest collected it
through generations of natural selection
we have a lot of an intuition that's
based on collecting data from being
babies and so on but they are very far
in terms of the machine learning from
knowing how to collect this prior
knowledge how to find relevant features
without human intervention without some
prior knowledge that can't swim in it
that's what they wanted learn to say
alright so so those sort of information
serious issues I think you know we can
we can wave as one of the success
stories of machine learning theory some
of the other things that that and more
current focuses good effort in that
direction in particular focuses of the
relations of machine learning program
this semester
you know how much creative we have much
less to boast about I guess is that the
right number so I'm going to say a
little bit about computational
challenges in machine learning and
issues with computational complexity so
again you know thinking of this picture
where we have we all come up with a
prediction rule that takes an image and
produces let's say an appropriate
caption and we're wanting to try to
learn to do that though to understand
what are appropriate settings of these
parameters from training data so we can
ask the question you know what how much
computation is required to find suitable
value proposed right how much
computational effort that we need to go
to so just to get a little more concrete
than this picture of a box with many
knobs on it let's talk about deep
networks that as I mentioned so these
are a class of prediction rules that
have been very successful in many of
these practical applications so let me
say at a high level what they're doing
so for the example of taking image in
producing a caption or a label of some
sort we get together successively
computing more complex functions of the
image so we start out in which of these
circles is representing some sort of a
computational unit each one has some
parameters associated with it so you
know seems to think those knobs that we
can adjust to change the function of one
these one of these units and information
flows through this network from the
image to the the output and and
typically what you find after training
this thing after coming up with estimate
of the parameters is that each
successive layer is consuming something
a little more complex for the light so
you know initially for an image the
early layers might be computing things
like location orientation edges and then
combinations of such features and you
know much richer combinations of those
features until at the upward hopefully
we're getting a sensible caption for
this for this image
so actually this sort of approach using
these sorts of prediction rules has been
very successful in practice over the
last ten years you know it's led to many
of these would be successes and in fact
the ones that I described earlier all of
them involved deep neural nets of this
kind okay so you know this is an
empirical success and we might ask for
what can we say about that theoretically
right so you know what is an effective
approach to finding good values of the
parameters in such a network let's say
to get training done so that we perform
well you know given the images in our
training training sets that we come up
with sensible reactions images how might
we do that what if you step back and
think about it you know we have a bunch
of knobs to adjust we could think about
trying all values right try every
setting of levels we maybe maybe they
have ten ten values we try the first one
there are ten different locations the
second one for each of those ten we have
ten different values to try right that's
for each combination of those there are
a hundred of those we try ten different
days at the third one and so on okay so
some of them sound like such a great
approach right it's not a great approach
because this number grows exponentially
with the number of parameters right so
you know that's that's very bad news
it's not as if we need bigger and bigger
computers to solve this exponential
growth right
potential growth is is kind of fatal and
you know this is really nice story about
the Indian king that was so thrilled
with the invention of the game of chess
that he offered the inventor you know
whatever he wished for within reason of
course and the inventor said fine you
know give me just just some rice one
grain to the first first square on the
chess board and then double it on each
square you know two on the second or
fourth and he thought this was fine to
you you're actually going to calculate
the cafeteria W gets a very large number
somebody did the calculation at you know
on the 64th squared if you could grow
ten grains of rice for each square inch
then you know to to provide the right
you need for that square you'd have to
cover the census of the earth with rice
packages including the ocean
okay so exponential growth is terrible
you know this is not going to work I
guess the bad news is that in some sense
you know in the level of generally dive
that I've described it we can't prove
that there's any better approach right
so you know this this is pretty terrible
so what's used in practice actually is
something much simpler I'll call the
local greedy updates the buzzword is
stochastic gradient descent and and how
this worked is you take a single
training example or a single image and
the caption that that is associated with
that image you provide that to this to
this system and then you go and tweak
the premise wherever the knobs are you
can work out pretty easily you know fix
all the others and and think of just one
of these laws should I do jumping it up
or down which is about in terms of the
caption that I'd like to produce and you
go do that for all dogs just adjust them
all a very very small amount then throw
that example out we've one of the next
ones you going like that okay very
simple I the thing it turns out this is
really hugely successful in practice and
again you know we don't really know why
I think it's fair to say we don't really
know what
there are some results you know there's
progress in this situation we can we can
prove something you know we can get get
some sort of performance guarantee but
that set of situations is you know
rather deficient and and you know it's
been a lot of work in expanding the
boundary of what we can fruit revolt
results about so this sort of this sort
of approach but you know it's certainly
a very active ongoing research area to
understand you know what are the
limitations of these proposals for
protected so these are some of the
topics that we're focused on this
example or the topics we focus on for
the foundations of machine learning
program this semester one other one is
interactive learning and Andres is going
to tell us about that and and some
issues of safety in the Sheila okay so
what I like to start by thanking those I
mean to touch the whole thing is a term
in the fantastic machine learning
program and I'd like to talk a little
bit about one of the themes like the
dimensions namely interacts with machine
learning and from the merchants issues
basically even using machine learning
for the pictures that came up several
times now of what machine learning is in
practice most of the time is that we
start with the large data set may be
images labels of capital art or legal
protections etc and then our goal is the
learning prediction rule to induce to
attach a label to something which we
haven't seen yet we separate training
and then once we have to change the Mong
train the appliance make predictions on
vehicles but there's lots applications
you might want to think about learning
systems that learn while they
interacting with a part maybe the most
prominent example of this that smoking
you lose it in the deal with I recommend
a societal system that recommend which
movie you might want to watch which
product you should buy online maybe
which posts you should read on your
friends time our feeds on Facebook etc
right and the data see systems work is
the observe how these exact words that
type
is that with the content that they show
to us for example how to be light soon
be that they recommend it to us but if
you buy the product they recommended us
but let me click on the feet of this
shop ok and so it's actually the
decision that learning courses may
affect the very days of that these
systems learn on alright there's not a
single fact that given ahead of time but
it's also good to access fees by
infecting with this environment learning
something
alright that's very important paradigm
many other education system and one of
the abstractions models that let us
reason about these things already came
up in in China talk is called with
enforcement learning and to hear you
think about an agent maybe a recommender
systems but interacts with the
environment the carrying out some
actions may be recommending a movie to
watch and then that might affect the
state of the environment and also affect
the reward you get right whether after
example they actually likely lead us
astray
okay and that leads to a crucial
challenge and called the exploration
exploitation dilemma whereas the system
needs to figure out that how should I
show examples to learn more about how
the world works where it's how can I use
what I've learned about how the world
works in order to make good decisions
why do I may be shown me to figure out
your preferences or do I take my best
guess of your preferences to show movie
that you like right and this is very
familiar to all of us let's we decided
to go with restaurant to doctor you can
choose to go to a new clinical to those
our favorite restaurant okay and so now
doing both were dining at around for
many years now but that's been spreading
as successes in the recent years
so one is already mentioned that during
the talk the obstacles are read for some
joining agent is over
okay can you maybe fit that question
later okay so the gear theories are
intact to the environment so there's
many other examples right so for example
there's general purpose reinforcement
learning agents that learn to play Atari
games at a superhuman level or earlier
the scared of an announcement for the
reinforcement learning agent able to
obtain No Limit Texas Hold'em poker at
degrees okay so a lot of these really
tough challenges that the community has
been working for many many years has
been falling over the last couple years
so this is really a marketable programs
so with all this excitement there's
temptation to use these systems right
through more more complex and highly
paid applications maybe use them to
learn to drive our cars right or to
control our park system in order to make
them more energy efficient right or
maybe even recommend in treatment
services ribbet recruit Delta mission
right now if you think about training a
computer report learning aging to play a
game that's a very easy thing to do
because you can play lots and lots of
stimulation right we're on reinforcement
learning agents essentially compete
against these ordinary experiment with
different moves etc to try to improve
with the strategy but it's not important
to us employing these systems in the
real world then essentially exploration
collecting data then just to try
something you haven't tried before
right and that potentially can be really
dangerous regulation is thinking about
facing a challenge and dissertation
Magnavox is interesting challenges
important research challenges upon how
to rigorously reason about reliability
security safety etc of machinery so I'd
like to talk about one sustaining here
in the context of robotics so that's a
paradigm very important or interesting
that are usually successful right now
you might want to example learn help to
death control strategies for complex
robotic systems and that is a very
difficult task so that's the listen
daunting progress over the recent years
but it is a very tough time problem so
here's the video
the chosen up takes
[Music]
so clearly you can't just go ahead and
do arbitrary exploration
I think question about the origination
reasonable the consequences of action
that you've ever tried perform but you
need to try them in order to collect
data right and that's the great Avenue
for theory and so one model that's been
explored is basically trying to
essentially optimize some unknown reward
functions for example is optimizing the
Department of the robot at some time as
a function of theta control parameters
that you plug in but the same time you
don't know ahead of time whether any of
these actions could say we wanted to
model this which have some sort of
constraints to be required right that
the actions did you try is actually safe
but you don't know I have assigned what
is safe you sort of need to figure out I
need to be cautious governed explore it
right and the question is how is
rigorously reasonable right you also be
able to essentially learn to improve at
some time while the same time figuring
out what is safe for now right and this
is a very difficult problem in general
there's no free lunch like the Stratos
mentioning with talk before and so it's
very interesting to trying to spend
under what circumstances can we actually
make rigorous assertion about safety of
Lisa and then the some source functions
that actually possible responses to
prove it was high probability the
systems very good experience and days
action while enzymes
converging to a good solution if you
have enough assumptions be able to
conduct them so here's a little
demonstration of this one is very simple
our control task is the first of the
year that start from an initial position
slice to target position this is a very
simple task
right but what the robot no does it
starts with a very poor initial
controller and autonomously decides how
the experiment tweak its knobs right to
make its own parameters in order to try
to get better at a task at the same time
there's lots of parameter settings that
will immediately crash the robot
against against the wall okay just very
cautiously explore figure out what is
actually feasible and while exploring
the feasible region try to optimize on
the phone okay and please this will just
run for a couple more experiments 30s on
top of Nelson
that resulted on citizens I mean ideas I
mean a very simple task right by the
demonstration of the kind of questions
you might be interested in exploiting
okay so they think you get so now that
to conclude SVM I want to make use of
the power of machine learning in real
applications with high and higher state
it's not about just optimizing accuracy
anymore right just a really rigorous is
thinking about constraints imposed on
these systems related to safety
reliability but other action stations
lighting cuz the dependency privacy and
one of the other notions of teachers and
amines talked at the end of this
particular presentation are related to
fairness so
[Applause]
so by culture via the connector software
DISA
matrix or MT symmetric berkeley this a
very good pleasure to be here especially
if you're coming from east coast
no matter which much better key so today
i'm going to talk about some aspects of
machine learning in that and if we're
science and Infernus and basically well
why do we you know one of the reasons
that we care about the network science
is that you know a lot of data that we
collect fractional networks and so for
instance a you know google and give you
60 seconds right only pick the second
google receiving four million search
requests or as they work around you know
people sharing two million more than to
maybe invent pieces of information over
sixty seconds and some of you are
contributing to this number right now
and reserve pretty much the same number
if you know 62 if you're uploading and
72 hours of media everything to set so
this is an explosion of data 3d sounds
in open networks and so very often we
actually know the structure of such
networks for instance we not need space
big facebook and twitter they know you
know how the network look like who is
frankly tomb we follow me to four
computer network we also knew pretty
much at least locally you know what
computers are connected to each other
individuals connected to two routers to
give you another example you know in for
transportation network you also know you
know which stations are connected to
each other and these are basically
public knowledge but very often it also
happens that we know that the network
exists but we don't know you know the
search
and I'm going to talk about the two
particular problem they one is about the
social price in a hard to reach
population these are two projects that
have been heavily involved in their last
a couple of here and the other one is
the functional connectivity Network and
I'm going to just explain a little bit
what the economy and and then you know
what say we could do about it
so the first one is you know this hard
to reach population or seeing the unseen
network and it basically relies on you
know art and easy question so if I go on
the street and randomly ask people you
know and if they voted probably not for
this election but for the previous one
people were willing to give you so this
is you know we don't it's a free country
so if you have an opinion right now so
this is a list this is an easy question
but what is a hard question if I you
know go out the next someone or your
luggage if you are you're not really you
know give me the answer if you're not
you pick up right so yeah and if I you
see I might actually get a function so
these are hard questions but so if we
want to understand for instance um
that the population of you know drug
users how they interact with each other
who is friends or you know people who
have HIV positive or you know actually
homosexual homosexuals in some certain
countries that if they reveal their and
their sexual orientation they might
actually face a severe punishment these
are quotes in that public health
community these are for hard to reach
population because it's you know they do
not allow outsiders to get in
to get information it's very difficult
for these Public Health Organization's
to get any kind of information about so
random sampling this is you know how we
collect data basically it's not going to
work and we have to come up with other
mistakes and over the last couple of
years a very interesting method came up
and right now many of the folks at
Health Organization are actually using a
very different kind of sampling not
random something that incentivize people
to give you some so what do they do they
say that this is the community this is
the population and and what they try to
do is that they find one personality at
a bar the drug user and giving money to
come to the service as in question steps
and then they give him a cup of
component and helping that if you go and
distribute the coupon to a friend for
articles and they can to the study you
all get my so the guy is very Santa very
nice to go and now distributing coupons
they get money for food or other things
and so this is basically that is the
first note they copy the anchor note
into another friend is rented into
another one and they come to the study
you know to test them and this is what
we actually do not hear so for instance
being you're trying to actually
understand the network of tourism in
Hartford the sitting and Tunisia now
this is also distorted version of
reality because these say you only get
drug use you don't get other people
there is no incentive to get out you
know usual ticket price and this is one
of the problems the other problem is
that we don't have you know a lot of
money to explore completely these
networks right so with the minimum
number of examples we won't understand
how people interact with each other and
this is what we have been involved and
there
you know machine learning tools help us
actually to understand with this
completely for example well you know one
thing that trying to talk about how we
can actually reason about you know who
he's connected with whom and then this
is going to be important information
because it has someone is connected to
everyone probably exactly the distillate
of the drugs and then we tested so there
are some anonymized actually a
population so these are the Dirk is
using computers work and the richer the
network is is not between anonymize but
so you know how the structure is known
and then be tested on man you know this
kind of data and now you're taking on
that obviously that we collected at
Connecticut so this is a one sort of
sign effort and the other one is it can
be used in the machines restraint and
that has been another project that I'm
with a student of mine and the universe
scientist at Yale we are trying to
experiment as tackle default so what do
what do we do as our deep sleep scanner
they put the people in them and you know
these are called Edison Roy machine and
as the image that you get is basically
they are going to be smoked out they
call them boxes around 1 million of them
and then these scanners you get the time
search like you know over that's a few
minutes the oxygen level on these very
small clinics so these huge amount of
data and and once they put people in the
scanner they ask them to do specific
tasks like reading or listening or
thinking or do nothing right and as well
you're trying to do is that you know can
we actually just look at this and we can
you say what they're do like without
knowing
so this is so and the way that we are
trying to do is to make so this is going
to be it this is a and ocean of data so
if you look at these data to individual
is completely different from each other
we cannot actually be singly you cannot
say anything if you look at these huge
amount of data so instead what we are
going to do is that we try to suppress
today to find you know important
information and then make the network
out of these you know huge data so
basically we these need urgent numbers
are given by neuroscientist because
these are meaningful biologically and
meaningful things so we make a small
effort at 30 of 30 nodes and then you
know make ages basically these nodes
represent different part of the brain
and their functionality and then how
they correlate with other parts of the
trainings whether they influence each
other or not and once we do that then
you know base of the so these are going
to be you know different kinds of
networks for different subjects for
different people and for different tasks
and the tasks were basically nine tasks
like language mode or gambling cetera
and also very interesting what that he
could actually predict what early it's a
very high accuracy so that is the
letting the chance is you know what
chance is is one of these nine that and
then you know basically eighty ninety
percent the time you can actually say
these are the faculties perfect and the
setting is a very coarse level of
understanding of reading the brain but
this is just the end of the story
so that was the tool project that I
wanted to talk about is then that we
have been involved and the last one took
you know it touches on people fight and
the last one was about you know we hear
it a lot about they think you know can
algorithm
racism you know what should we do about
it using the picture that actually I
have a 10 month old daughter and it's
last night at midnight in search for
babies these are cancers that occur and
I see no definition on Google and what
is wrong in this picture and they're
huge they are very good baby's fine
nothing what is that and they're mostly
what you have to go really down into the
search to actually get any sort skin so
you might say that well you know these
are key baby is fine I mean search but
the problem is that you know a lot of
these machine learning algorithms are
based on collecting data is web-based so
if you see all the white people you're
only going to learn about let's see this
is a very famous example Joe was
actually student MIT or postdoc and this
actually became serious BBC so what the
problem was that the computer could
recognize the white mass but couldn't
recognize the face the algorithm was not
designed to be racist but because it has
never seen dark face it could it didn't
learn them okay and then so there was
these a a eye beauty contest last year a
lot of people submitted I you know the
pictures and and and then there was this
AI George program behind it to select
you know the winner there were 45
winners only one of them had are all 43
of the rest were actually you know there
were white the enterprise associated
with them
you have very low chance if you have
seen and then you know another thing is
there another example is the under the
prime so lacquer gaining people figure
out that
excluded some neighbor who's in now you
know six cities that had their minority
and for the sweet same-day delivery and
then when they a comes on you know why
are you racist if they well medians of
anything is the algorithm decided and
the algorithm decided because it's a
predicted we are not going to make any
money in those neighborhoods okay so but
it's not that someone maliciously is
behind these algorithms to make them you
know to make them practice but somehow
through the data they pick up on
features that probably in issue and this
is the you know brings us to the idea of
the furnace if you know you go to a bank
for your loan and then someone you know
based on the skin of your color lift the
color of your skin they you know they
say okay your your rate it can be much
higher that's not okay now we can decide
based on that picture look one way
another we have to correct it out and
you know make the boy regarding yourself
protective features a slower and so that
was say an oak tree one of the things
that we discussed during this program
man it's a real challenge you know they
are not very good solutions out there
and but we hope that you know to
discussion is you find something that
you know the things on the algorithms in
work well but they pretend to be first
are nothing to report
so these are formulas for imitating week
both muttering somehow has to reach
without opponent for the Sultana
speculate the consequences and so that
we will be activated at work other
commercial parties and in principle
there's nothing speaking against using
your neighbor type case based reasoning
methods like and say for estimating down
time action right so these are hard all
our point effective marriages are
getting that opportunity could you have
your uncertain engines that in specify
the kind of auto-generated the form of
use cases substitution would look how
many ways with my measurements on
learning so it's kind of a hiding some
interesting
the instruction for again these are
ovulation correct I have no reason why
insights and certain applications where
a case based reasoning has been in a
fight certain age until you receive the
piece of company a long time coming a
few seconds it's a very good thought
right one personally would a and racism
there's also yeah wanting to hear other
side of example that you have not shown
very special on face of them are
recognized and this actually came in the
news a boo-boo face recognized
recognizing algorithms from
african-american basis and it actually
classified it as going on here I printed
actually game of the new birth so white
point going to it's saying is sleep may
actually point to get the foul of them
so no they they are not human so they
explode white black brown etc but what I
would like to say that this simply means
the feature extraction technology has
not advanced to the point where its
optimum and again nothing one of the
conventions is also an exponential
problem but I think that's made point to
that thought but I mean I don't know but
this is all done what the hell is
anything is the number of training
patents that were then use could please
could be predominantly white and in dual
patterns even if it's as a mix of black
the lack of feature extractions on the
later cases which just make them into
false positives [ __ ] them to I mean I
don't know yeah that is when they
actually try to correct you know so as
you said it was in only news and and
right the day after they you know they
switch the algorithm in order to make
sure that it is not going to happen
right and so it was very manual right
this is one issue the other thing is
that you know it's not only one feature
one you know it's not only the skin of
the color the color of the skin is going
to be you know feature that you have to
protect your other features that can
employ yes through directory right so
and we don't know of any
rigorous way of attacking this problem
at least for now all the all the
solutions are just Hansard so there's
actually a more subtle issue later as
well right so you think about the the
Amazon example it may have been totally
correct then in those neighborhoods is
you know that the prediction of having
less profit is accurate right and if it
make that prediction based on you know
the proportion of people of one race
versus another it might still be
accurate yeah but it's inappropriate for
the precision to be made on that sort of
a yet I'm a socialist when even though
it's not any the question about the
median stay on top it's like from an
algorithmic perspective my trolley
optimizing a top sponsor and say year my
costs are low or even negative and it
looks like that but I tried optimising
wrong another difference with it itself
its job thank you in my timing for light
being so socially conscious about the
bias algorithms right however in his
first part of the presentation all of
these my groups that you mentioned have
been prosecuted at one point or another
so you're a force into probing the
internal structure of those prosecuted
groups is deeply disturbing those
techniques can be used today for that
particular purpose tomorrow for some
other purpose should not we be more
careful before creating algorithms that
can be used for unintended that's
actually a very very good point one
thing is that I didn't mention actually
at the presentation is that these data
when we get actually the data is heavily
anonymous so there are invisible
different methods of the right data
thread so the individual cannot be
identified does doesn't matter for this
end goal is to expose those groups
figure out how they work how they
function who those people are finding
and prosecute them like try being a gay
in 1950s Britain and you were persecuted
and you know where our examples of it
santé scientists so again although
you're very conscious about the outcome
of these algorithms and their impact in
the previous part of your work cutting
pieces in the agree that equality really
we are going to be issues like you know
if these communities should be protected
so the main purpose of our work work
work good health right so we wanted to
provide better health for it for those
people but I agree that we have to be
conscious about you know what we're
doing and and again there is a you know
it's so here's the thing you can have a
knife and are many ways used this
particular case is very clear all right
question one of the I in your classes we
using a cloud online machine learning
platform like as your visual one is
suitable for this your at anybody like
Microsoft Azure machine learning husband
watering if it's suitable for use with a
class
we certainly do yeah what did it a big
on people on small computer you can
actually do anything right it's a very
good club yeah I you basically try
actually to run things on the cloud and
it's not that it's very cheap and easy
all right so it's 11 o'clock no people
have to go to other things that you'd
like to hang around and ask other
questions you're welcome to do that
here
[Applause]